there is a complete lockdown at the grc
meeting in lower manhattan
uh not a lockdown on the rules of
wearing earrings on the job these things
look amazing but someone's gonna rip
them out of your ears in a scuffle also
if you thought we weren't going to sin
news position just because it's audio
only we probably need to get to know
each other better so we can avoid these
kinds of miscommunications in the future
saying there's no fly zone in effect
while using footage that specifically
appears to be shot from a flying vehicle
and yes i get it they can put cameras
wherever they want but my cognitive
dissonance kicked in and it made me
angry
[Music]
it seems like some serious effort would
have gone into applying this fake face
so why rip it off to prove it's you tell
him a secret only the two of you would
know like the diameter of his left
testicle
also this tech is incredible it doesn't
even rip off face hair
or remove blackheads relax no one's
looking for me here even if they were
you made it really easy to spot you now
that you've removed that super high-tech
face mask for absolutely no reason yes
you won't be needing wait
crap rewind it guess you won't be
needing this
anymore phew thank you you're risking a
lot of coming here
i hear pardons arnold's are cracked up
to be anyway how are these two speaking
to each other right now
hey bobby you get that gas grenade done
yet nah i'm still trying to design that
opening mechanism that separates into
three geometrical pleasing sections to
let a neon green light shine out between
them
damn it poppy not everything has to be
an homage to the matrix we need those
things like
yesterday [ __ ] you frank i'm an artist
so the building was attacked while sam
was back home he then dons his new wings
and flies to new york where carly waits
to see him in the sky before initiating
the smoke bomb attack meaning
all these chuckles were just hanging out
in the conference room with doors they
could have run out at any point yes
mcu officially passes on a main
character title for the first time in
it's absolutely badass
and to those who would say that maki
could never carry the shield as well as
his predecessor i have one thing to say
that's cap i mean i guess we had to find
a new interpretation of the headpiece
but
functionally how does it stay stuck to
his head is the middle strap section
so tight that it clamps it in place how
do you properly contemplate saving
people when your brain is being squeezed
by a cranial jock strap he's wearing a
jock strap for his face and now he'll
never unsee it
you're welcome you cost me a lot of
money
oh good we get to go back to the bat
rock plot line everyone was clamoring
for i swear the only time i want to hear
the word bat rock again is if christian
bale ben affleck and will arnett start
touring as a death metal band
camera descends a spiral staircase down
the middle and blasphemes vertigo in the
process cliche
captain america suddenly forgets that he
has a shield despite spending 56 percent
of the last episode training with one
that's how you feel you should sit this
one out well you know i ain't gonna do
that bucky's already sitting this one
out considering that since his phone
call started he's just
standing there walk and talk bucks walk
and talk
seriously bucky you had one job since
everyone can talk through their magical
earpieces why would sharon take
this long to check in with bucky and how
does a phone call with carly distract
buggy in the first place and yes i
already seen that but
that's one down how'd you manage that
murder chopper's about to take off
[ __ ] it i don't fly man that's your
thing at this point these communicators
are just magic right mcu is just like
look we need our characters to be able
to throw quips at each other at all
times and we're not letting things like
distance or logic stop us
you don't think lamar's life matters i
mean to be fair as much as we knew about
them they might as well have dressed
them in a red shirt and been done with
it so maybe direct your question at the
writers on this one
john
parking meters i'm digging a lot of this
action i really am but it sure does seem
like the formula for these mtu finales
is just going to be punch punch wink of
themes punch punch plot twist punch
punch false resolution punt the big
stuff to the movies doesn't it
yes put in your earbuds that you not
only happen to have on you after being
rushed out of the building but are also
charged and completely inconspicuous
also not punctuating your text messages
you're better than that captain america
or
red wing or whoever the hell sent this
text however the hell they sent it a
little birdie told me
all right that's enough did they tap
into her earbuds did she answer a call
this shows text sells more convenience
than 7-eleven casey's murphys and wawa
combined
this countdown is complete tension
building nonsense all you had to say is
when i take out the pilot immediately
grab the controls
instead of relying on two people
reaching the count of five at the same
time in a situation where you don't even
know how long it's gonna take you to
pull off the move
if she gets to five before you and tries
to grab the controls you might end up
taking both of them out and killing
everyone on the chopper
hey random plot device lady i'm taking
out the pilot when i do grab the
controls and
scene oh yay murderous crapton lamerica
is fighting the murderous flag smashers
and i guess i'm supposed to be rooting
for
the scene to end
a vehicle gets treacherously suspended
above a fall with innocent lives at
stake boy we're playing all the action
cliche hits today kiddos
and now maybe we're supposed to like
this guy again
john walker has rocketed through his
character arc without earning it so fast
he's basically the game of thrones
season 8 of the mtu
he's just a normal dude pushing a
two-ton truck with a jet pack
and somehow his back doesn't break he
doesn't even have a pulled muscle
afterwards
beautiful people bought into that bush
the comment section every time i remove
a sin
somehow makes it into the episode it's
like they want us to see this tech that
somehow tracks thermal footprints left
through boots and say it's wakanda text
so anything goes and
we can't do that well we could but we
don't want to
are they whistling to find each other
what a terrible idea do they not think
that whistles can be mimicked have they
not seen the hunger games
so you're the power broker i felt a
great disturbance in this plot twist
as if millions of voices suddenly cried
out in apathy and were suddenly
disinterested
where does it end apparently just above
the temples and honestly your cowl is
the most distracting thing i've seen
since the ball brawl
sharon must be feeling pretty confused
right now you know with sam rushing to
carly rather than to her
they're both dying of gunshot wounds
here i'm a black man
carrying the stars and stripes what
don't i understand
oh captain my captain look this show has
its share of bull
but this this is the good stuff i know
i've said it before but one last time
for being willing to go there marvel i
doff my cap
walker walks into a media frenzy where
no one asks him why he's there what he's
doing why he's in captain america gear
or what it feels like to be useless
super nice of the raft to provide
plot-spilling satellite radios for the
prisoners
it's the same but black i mean now
you're just saying the quiet part out
loud
i have to tell you something this
segment of bucky finally truly making
amends with his past is powerful and
would probably have earned another sin
off
if it weren't for the fact that it
included a positive nod to this terrible
therapist who needs her license revoked
and in no way deserves credit for any of
this
[Music]
stalking wait so you made an entire
section of the museum dedicated to this
man with his full name and information
on display and you didn't get permission
first this is the same man who didn't
even want to be bothered about any of
this just a few days ago so this is not
only a huge gamble but probably
unethical
this would be like holding a particular
award till the end of your award show
because you think you know who's going
to win and you could use it for your own
purposes
can you imagine i told you in the last
episode if this wasn't fixed i'd add 100
sins and i'm nothing if not a super
consistent completely fair man of my
word
we call it the denver jock strap sinners
go vows to our newest domain of
nifty delights and behold commercial
sins
oh and subscribe immediately so the
order goes click sub simple as that
oh actually watch the video jesus i
guess i need to make a flow chart
commercial sans go now
sir are you supposed to be here
i'd like to take his face off
red wing see if anyone in there has
flight training
sorry i'm having trouble understanding
right now
please try a little later
all day sharon
blocking my light ha ha sharon okay i
get it